Fox News host Mark Levin has been doing
a series of Sunday night interviews with
the failed former president Donald Trump
but last night's was so absurd that
Levin couldn't possibly save Trump when
Trump raises a conspiracy theory so
insane that it obviously doesn't make
any sense based on the facts but it is
such a verbal ink plot that you couldn't
possibly clean it up the topic was the
pandemic and Chinese tariffs and Trump's
claim is that China
made and released covid as punishment to
Trump and the United States of America
because Trump charged China so much
money in tariffs which ignores the fact
that Trump still doesn't understand how
tariffs work listen to this this is Mark
Levin can't possibly do anything with
this to save Trump China I was very from
I was probably the first one I said he
came from the lab in Wuhan I knew that
for one thing you saw body bags all over
the place around that lab you know there
were body bags all over
that area and nobody talks about it but
Levin is trying to stay as still as
possible to maybe blend into the
background and not even be visible in
Wuhan you had through satellite pictures
and other things you had pictures
body bags all over the place and you
could see little lines you know from way
up but they couldn't be anything else
but I said and I've said right from the
beginning it was the 11 it got out it
got out of the lab
I think it was incompetence I I really
believe it was incompetence well you
know people said I was charging China so
much money in tariffs and taxes that a
lot of people said they did it to get me
out
but we did great in that election we did
understand what Trump is saying okay
think about how Bonkers this is the
tariffs that he was charging China
angered them so much that China made and
released covid mostly killing people in
other countries like remember most of
the deaths were not in the United States
in order to get Trump back
now there's a couple little problems
with this one is that's that's not how
terrorists work Trump still doesn't get
that when you put tariffs on Chinese
products imported to the United States
American companies pay the tariffs you
are charging American companies more
you're not charging China
so it makes no sense on principle but of
course if the 6.8 million official
coveted deaths only and I say only like
it's not a lot it's an insane number but
the point is proportionately of the 6.8
million covet deaths only 1.1 million
were in the United States so China to
get Trump back for tariffs that they
didn't actually pay did something to
kill 5.7 million people in other
countries including their own in order
to kill some people in the U.S many
after Trump left office as punishment
for Trump's tariffs which they didn't
pay this is so stunning stunningly
stupid that even Mark Levin says nothing
and is just motionless like a statue
Trump then brings up Abraham Lincoln
and says that he has actually been
treated worse than Abraham Lincoln
remember Abraham Lincoln was
assassinated say that Andrew Jackson was
the most vilified president it was his
wife died during this thing and they
said such horrible things and he had a
very tough presidency he was a very good
president he was a great General and a
good president
Abraham Lincoln they say was you know he
had a civil war going they say it all
right but uh Abraham Lincoln had was
just vilified he was
but now they say Trump got treated the
worst of all really because what they
did is they came up with phony stuff
Russia Russia Russia it was all hoaxes
uh the Mueller Witch Hunt which turned
out to be no collusion you know after
two and a half years no collusion I
could have told him that the first day
and they had the laptop they could have
figured that out because on the laptop
if you look at it you could have figured
that out easy but uh there's never been
anything despite that people is this the
most demented malignant narcissist
public figure of all time they say that
Trump was treated worse than Lincoln
Lincoln was shot in the head and killed
Trump was investigated for pretty
obvious wrongdoing and then Trump claims
that he sent former German Chancellor
Angela Merkel a white flag of surrender
to symbolize uh Germany I guess
surrendering to Russia I didn't allow
Germany to get away with what they were
doing I sent Angela Merkel a white flag
of surrender because I said when you
made the deal with Putin you're getting
68 of your energy from somebody that
you've had numerous Wars with world wars
I said so I'm going to give you the
White Flag this way you don't have to
look it up when you surrender to Russia
someday yeah it'd be like the U.S doing
business with Germany even though in the
past we were on opposing sides of a war
oh wait a second we do that all the time
what kind of an argument is that and if
you remember I made a speech at the
United Nations and the Russian delegates
that's when everybody laughed and
thought it was extremely funny when I
mentioned
that they shouldn't be doing it a year
later most of those guys were fired it
was actually the entire room that was
laughing at Trump because that speech
was so ridiculous lastly Trump takes
credit for the Olympics in South Korea
being a sellout it started off rough
remember that uh I was saying a little
rocket man you're not going to get on
and I was saying a little recommend and
he was saying uh I've got a red button
on my desk and I'm willing to use it and
I say I have a red button too and mine's
bigger and mine works and all sorts of
things it was very nasty and then all of
a sudden we get a phone call they want
to meet
and then I made the Olympics accessory
remember in South Korea they were having
the Olympics in nine months and nobody
was buying a ticket because they didn't
want to be have missiles shot at them
during the Olympic Opening Ceremonies
under understand what Trump is saying
he's saying the South Korean Olympics
would have been a failure had he not met
with North Korean dictator Kim Jong-un
because people would have been scared of
missile attacks during the Olympics in
South Korea
but thanks to Trump meeting with Kim
Jong-un where nothing was accomplished
by the way that made the South Korean
Olympics popular this is a good time to
mention I mentioned it it mentioned it
earlier in the show Bradley hope has a
new book called The Rebel in the Kingdom
it's not about Trump uh it's actually
about an activist related to North Korea
fascinating book extremely well
researched but because of the timing of
when the book takes place there's a lot
in the book that explains Trump's total
failure when it comes to North Korea I
will admit I learned in the book that
some of Trump's instincts from the
deal-making business world
theoretically could have actually been
effective with Kim Jong-un
they weren't because Trump's execution
was a disaster and it really built up a
more nuanced understanding for me of
trump dealing with North Korea but if
you really want to understand again the
book is not mostly about it but the
story will give you an understanding of
Trump's failures with North Korea and
Kim Jong-un get the book The Rebel in
the Kingdom by Bradley hope I just
finished reading it yesterday
by now all of us know how creepy it is
to talk to a friend about something and
then get ads that are related when you
use a free email service from a big Tech
Corporation your emails are scanned even
if you're emailing your spouse or your
doctor which is why I recommend start
mail the email service that never scans
or analyzes your email our sponsor start
mail also lets you create unlimited
email address aliases so you don't even
have to give out your real email address
this protects you from spam and phishing
attacks phishing attacks are becoming
way more sophisticated with the rise of
chat GPT by the way start mail lets you
encrypt any email you send even if the
recipient isn't using encryption unlike
the big Tech email Services who store
even your deleted emails when you delete
an email in start mail it is gone
migrating from your current email
service to start mail is just a few
clicks so what are you waiting for stop
letting big Tech corporations spy on
your email my audience gets 50 off your
first year at startmail.com Pacman the
link is down below